[Music]
they say you should always prepare for
the worst but it turns out that these
beloved actors didn't have to from
horror classics to historical epics
these had Movies featured stars who
weren't exactly optimistic about their
work during production Boogie knights
was seen by many as a comeback movie for
Bert Reynolds the peak of his Fame was
already long behind him and he had spent
much of the '90s in forgettable if not
outright embarrassing films for the
first time in a good number of years he
was getting praise for his in and he
would go on to win a Golden Globe and be
nominated for an Oscar for his
performance as adult filmmaker Jack her
surely Reynolds appreciated what Boogie
Knights did for his career right not
even close Reynolds famously bashed the
film every chance he got and continued
to express regret for his involvement as
recently as 2015 18 years after the
movie's release and just 3 years before
his death the veteran actor claimed that
he didn't even want to do the movie in
the first place and said that he had
turned it down seven times before
finally giving in Reynolds also said
that he hated working with writer and
director Paul Thomas Anderson so much so
that he had to be physically held back
from assaulting the filmmaker if that
wasn't enough Reynolds just wasn't
impressed with the movie or its subject
matter and he didn't see how anyone else
possibly could be you wanted to hit the
director Paul Thomas Anderson you wanted
to hit him in the face no I don't want
to hit him in the face I just wanted to
hit him the 2007 movie 300 was arguably
the breakout project for both its
director and its lead actor Zack Snyder
had received a claim for his Dawn of the
Dead remake but it was with 300 that he
truly established the filmmaking style
that would follow him for much of his
career to come as for Gerard Butler
leonitis was far from his first film
role but it was his first huge hit as
the top build player when looking back
at the film in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter Butler revealed that
he and Snyder connected immediately
during their first meeting and were
mutually excited to work together but
once the actor got on set it was a
different story 300 was filmed entirely
in front of blue screens with its
backgrounds filled in digitally during
post- production something much more
common now than it was at the time it
was certainly a new experience for
Butler and he had a lot of trouble
envisioning what the final product would
actually look like as a result while
watching an actor reacting to a burning
Village while simply pointing at a blue
screen he couldn't help but think oh my
God this movie is going to suck once
Butler saw the finished film with the
added effects however he was blown away
and thankfully for both him and Snyder
audiences were too Friday the 13th bad
guy Jason Vorhees has become an icon of
the horror genre the hockey mask covered
face of the long-running franchise he's
appeared in everything from Comics to a
Mortal Kombat game but he wasn't the bad
guy in the first Friday most of the
killing in the 1980 slasher movie was
done by Jason's mother Pamela who was
played by the late Betsy Palmer Palmer
once admitted that the only reason she
appeared in the film was because she
needed a new car and she had her eye on
a Volkswagen sraco as soon as she
realized that she would be portraying
the villain in a low-budget horror flick
Palmer assumed that the happenings at
Camp Crystal Lake would come and go
without much fanfare as she admitted so
the script came and I read it and said
what a piece of sh no one is ever going
to see this it will come and it will go
and I will have my Saka instead Friday
the 13th was a Smash Hit turning Pamela
Vorhees and her son into horror icons
don't let her get away mommy don't let
her live I won't Jason I won't Tommy Lee
Jones is known for playing noons
characters that aren't afraid to hurt
feelings and if his co-stars are to be
believed Jones himself has a similar
reputation from his disdain of Jim
Carrey on the set of Batman Forever to
his clashes with director Barry son
enfeld during the production of Men In
Black there might be a good reason why
Jones is frequently typ cast as a
crotchy grunt even while working on the
movie that earned Jones's only Academy
Award thus far The Fugitive Jones still
didn't seem all that happy to be there
he also didn't seem to think the movie
was any good in a rolling stone oral
history of the film Jones recalled a
moment when he was filming a scene and
things just weren't falling into place
so he immediately assumed that the worst
was going to happen as he put it I
remember thinking in the back of my mind
I'll never work again this is never
going to work and the best thing I can
do is be as clear concise and coherent
as possible deliver these lines as
cleanly and dutifully as possible and
maybe I'll get another job one day
somewhere down the line like many people
in Hollywood Chris Pratt was hesitant to
believe the first Guardians of the
Galaxy movie could succeed after all the
Guardians were a c-list squad with far
less name recognition than the Avengers
and X-Men both Pratt and director James
gun admitted that they were both worried
that their careers would be over if as
some pundits predicted the film turned
out to be Marvel's first bomb Pratt in
particular was amazed that Marvel even
opted to fund the project remarking
about Hollywood Executives everyone
wants to win big but no one wants to
gamble the actor continued every rule
said you don't make a movie with the
Talking Tree you don't spend this much
money on a raccoon with a gun for me I
was like oh so this movie is going to
bomb done this is the end of my career
there's a little pee coming out of me
right now more than $700 million and
heaps of critical praise later the
Guardians were household names Pratt was
the face of a franchise and gun was one
of Hollywood's hottest writer directors
it may have come out two decades ago but
elf is still one of the newer films to
be added to the list of Undisputed
Christmas classics directed by John
favro before his jump to Marvel and Star
Wars the movie stars will frell is Buddy
a human man who grew up among Santa's
toy making elves after he learns the
truth about his existence buddy makes
his way to America and he gets into some
pretty wacky hij Jinks once he arrives
will frell is one of the most famous
comedians around nowadays but in 2003 he
had only recently left Saturday Night
Live and was still beefing up his
filmography he still had a famous face
though while filming the outdoor scenes
for elf in New York City the cameras
were hidden so that frell could get some
real reactions of of real people
unfortunately some of those people
recognized him and as a result they
expressed concern over the fact that he
was walking around in an elf costume and
asked if he was doing okay the
experience made the actor question
whether the movie was going to work on
the big screen Annie worried that it was
going to effectively end his movie
career just as it was beginning
obviously the movie ended up resonating
with a lot of people and elf was a hit
in its day before it became an enduring
classic of the holiday season Richard
dfus was was fortunate enough to star in
several undeniably classic films fairly
early in his career as he ended up on
the radar as a future icons George Lucas
and Steven Spielberg early in their
respective Hollywood Journeys American
Graffiti ended up being D's first big
role and he added both jaws and Close
Encounters of the Third Kind to his
resume before the end of the 1970s with
jaws dfus got to be part of the movie
that is often said to have invented the
very concept of the summer blockbuster
and everyone involved seemed to
understand that it was something special
everyone it seems except for dfus in a
career retrospective he did for Yahoo
dfus said of the vibe on the Jaws set
everyone had thought they had struck
gold and I said what are you talking
about it's just a little movie so when
the film was released I found myself
going back to the talk shows and saying
I'm the guy who didn't believe in it he
couldn't have been more wrong Jaws was
so big that it set new standards for
what it means for a movie to be big Bill
Murray voicing the main character in
2004's Garfield the movie felt like a
full circle moment for many fans
Garfield's voice from 1982 to 2001 was
an actor named Lorenzo music and he also
played Peter vinman in the cartoon The
Real Ghostbusters since music died in
2001 he couldn't voice the liveaction
Garfield so who better to step in than
the original liveaction Peter vman Still
Nostalgia wasn't the reason Murray
signed on to voice everyone's favorite
lasagna loving fat cat when he saw that
the movie was co-written by Joel Cohen
he jumped at the chance to work with one
of the esteemed Cohen Brothers who
proved their comedy chops with Raising
Arizona and the big Labowski as Murray
was recording his lines he was shocked
at how bad he thought they were but he
stuck with it and tried to make the best
of it when things didn't improve he
asked to watch back the scenes that had
already been cut together and he
remarked out loud who the hell cut this
thing who did this what the was Cohen
thinking that's when someone informed
Murray that it wasn't the Oscar winner
Joel Cohen who had worked on Garfield
but Joel Cohen with an H at that point
he was too deep to back out so he
finished the job on what ended up being
a box office hit so do you have any
regrets Garfield
maybe Australian actor Jeffrey Rush
knows his way around an Oscar caliber
performance he's delivered four so far
winning for shine and receiving
nominations for Shakespeare and love
quills and The King's Speech that
doesn't mean he always knows going into
a project that it's going to be a
claimed let alone that anyone is even
going to be bothered to see the movie at
all he had serious doubts about one of
those very projects and he ended up
eating his words despite his prediction
The King's Speech was an Undisputed
success Rush reminisced on the moment he
first received the script for the
historical drama about King George V 6's
struggles with stuttering recalling when
when we sat and read the initial script
the first thing I read was well no one
will want to go and see this let alone
oh this is an Oscar worthy film with
that in mind Rush found it rather funny
when people accused the movie of being
so-called Oscar bait but whether or not
that was the case it snagged an
impressive 12 nominations and won four
including best picture as for Russ's
assumption that nobody would go see it
the King speech was a surprisingly
massive box office hit for a movie of
its kind netting over 400 million at the
worldwide box office it's no big secret
that Robert patson was never entirely
comfortable with the level of Fame that
starring in Twilight brought him
thankfully he's done more than enough
acclaimed work since then to
successfully distance himself from the
five movie franchise and nowadays he's
more commonly associated with films like
the Batman and the lighthouse but why
would patson take on the role of the
famously sexy vampire Edward Cullen if
he didn't want to be a globally famous
hard throp it turns out that Patterson
didn't think Twilight was going to be
that big at all when he first auditioned
and eventually accepted the role even
though Stephanie Meyer's urban fantasy
Saga was an unavoidable phenomenon in
the United States it was apparently much
less popular in patson's Native London
he claimed that when he tried to buy the
books for research after he was cast in
the first movie he couldn't find any
stores in the city that even sold them
he also stated that among his circle of
friends and family he only knew one
person who had read the books a friend
of his sisters given all that along with
the fact that director Katherine
Hardwick had only done relatively small
films up to that point pson had no
reason to expect Twilight to make much
of an impact even though Jackie Chan was
an international action movie Superstar
dating back to the 1970s he struggled
for years to fully break into Hollywood
it wasn't until Rumble in the Bronx made
it to the states in 1996 that Chan
finally got the crossover hit that had
eluded him for so long 2 years later he
starred in the americanmade buddy cop
action comedy Rush Hour alongside
Comedian Chris Tucker and it ended up
being the biggest worldwide box office
hit of Chan's career up to that point
while filming rush hour though Chan
didn't think it was working he was
frustrated about not being given more
creative control over his fight scenes
and he had concerns about the language
barrier between himself and
Tucker do you understand the words that
are coming out of my
mouth Shan had no faith in rush hour at
all so much so that even when the
audience at the premiere was loving it
Chan told Yahoo that he was thinking why
are they laughing I just don't
understand the fact that Rush Hour
tanked in his native China only seemed
to reinforce Chan's feelings on the
movie's quality but it was an undeniably
huge hit in the US it sequel did even
better at both the US and worldwide box
offices even though Chan thought it was
even worse than the original James
Marist has had an interesting and varied
career one that includes comedies dramas
video game adaptation musicals superhero
movies and more he's also done his fair
share of romance films including one
that's especially iconic among fans of
the genre The Notebook the 2004 Nicholas
Sparks adaptation that stars Ryan
Gosling and Rachel McAdams in the lead
roles Maron played Lon Hammond the guy
who mcadam's Aly ends up with after she
thinks Gosling's Noah has stopped
writing to her and she later cheats on
him with Noah when they reconnect it's
all pretty standard Nicholas Sparks Fair
which is exactly what Mars and worried
about while he was making the movie in
an interview with Out magazine looking
back at his career he joked there are
some movies that I've been in that I was
sure people would laugh at that have
become huge I thought the notebook was
going to be a schaly movie of the week
type thing and here we are whether the
notebook is schaly or not is a matter of
opinion but as far as money is concerned
the raw data speaks for itself the movie
grossed over $100 million at the box
office and it Remains the best reviewed
Nicholas Sparks adap ation to date it
has since been reappraised in a less
positive light by a lot of people but
Forest Gump was a crowd-pleasing hit
when it came out in 1994 star Tom Hanks
even saw fit to come out and defend the
movie against its detractors saying that
it's only because the movie was such a
big hit that people have seen fit to
take shots at it in recent years it's
interesting to hear Hank's going to bat
for Forest Gump now considering that he
had moments in which he wasn't
especially confident in the movie while
the movie was being filmed during the
2023 New Yorker live event Hanks
admitted that he questioned director
Robert zamus on whether anyone was
really going to care about the movie or
its lead character he asked zus this guy
sitting on a thing in these goofy shoes
and this cuckoo suit with a suitcase
full of Curious George books and stuff
like that are we doing anything here
that is going to make any sense to
anybody Hanks claims that zamus did
little to reassure him instead the
director supposedly responded with we
may be sewing the seeds of our own
destruction
what's my destiny
mom you're going to have to figure that
out for yourself it all worked out fine
including best actor and Best Director
Oscar wins for the duo Beyond a few
cameos Rita Moreno was the only member
of the original Westside Story movie
cast to play a major role in the 2021
Steven Spielberg directed remake in the
1961 version she was Anita while in the
2021 film she played an entirely new
character named named Valentina her
connection to both films makes her an
important part of the overall Westside
Story Legacy which makes it all the more
surprising that she didn't think the
original movie directed by Robert Weiss
and Jerome Robbins was going to be a
success in a 2021 appearance on 60
Minutes Moreno admitted flat out I
didn't even think the movie was going to
do that well she went on to explain that
she pulled her co-star George chakiris
aside on the set one day and prepared
him for the worst she said nobody was
going to want to see the movie because
it lacked f fancy costuming had very
operatic singing at times and was about
gangs that danced Moreno made sure to
point out that she found the movie to be
brilliant it's just that she didn't
think it would connect with movie
goinging audiences but it very much did
and it won her an Oscar which was her
first step toward her eventual egot
anyone who worked on the first couple of
entries of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
could be forgiven for being unsure if
they were making a hit but when the
Avengers broke the billion dooll Mark in
2012 there was no denying that the
franchise was a massive success hype
only grew for the MCU and when Avengers
endgame arrived in theaters 7 years
later it was less of a film release and
more of a worldwide cultural event
considering that it became the highest
grossing film ever at the time in just 3
months it's hard to imagine that anyone
was pessimistic about its chances for
success and yet Scarlet Witch actor
Elizabeth olssen worried about that very
thing regarding the Epic climax of the
mcu's first three phases during a late
night interview with Jimmy Fallon she
admitted that it's difficult for her to
watch herself in new Marvel films
because she always assumes that they'll
do poorly I I saw Avengers endgame and I
looked around me and I said is it our
first flop Avengers endgame is one of
the biggest movies in the history of the
world yeah only several movies in the
MCU have disappointed at the box office
and Elizabeth Olsson hasn't appeared in
any of them it seems that audiences
always turn out for the Scarlet witch
with near Universal Acclaim and hundreds
of millions of dollar made at the box
office it ranks among the most
critically and commercially successful
horror movies ever made that came as a
huge relief to actor Bill Skarsgard who
was convinced something would go wrong
during production he admitted in an
interview with variety I just felt like
something really terrible was going to
happen to me personally things just
seemed to be going too well even when
the film was projected to wildly surpass
the Studio's most conservative estimates
of success based on early reviews scars
guard still apparently managed to
convince himself something would come
along and undo it all nothing
particularly awful ended up happening
and even though it chapter 2 didn't
quite live up to the expectations set by
the first film the two movies brought in
over a billion dollars in total now all
that's left is for the world to decide
whether scars guard is a scary looking
hot guy a hot looking scary guy or
something in between if you had to guess
who in the cast of Home Alone was
skeptical of its potential to be a hit
or even a decent movie at all it would
be understandable to assume that the
person in question was Joe pesi while
there has been some anecdotal evidence
to suggest that to be the case it was
actually John herd the actor behind
patriarch Peter McAllister who loudly
expressed his doubts while appearing on
the podcast here's the thing with Alec
Baldwin director Chris Columbus
explained that John herd didn't seem to
think that Home Alone was any good
during production and he made sure that
everyone around him knew it once the
Final Cut of the film premiered though
herd had the same reaction as the
majority of viewers and greatly enjoyed
watching his onscreen son defend his
home from the wet Bandits Columbus
claimed that during the production of
Home Alone 2 lost in New York herd broke
character in the middle of a scene to
declare I just would like to say to
Chris and the crew I owe you a big
apology we made a great movie the first
time and I'm here to support you Edie
Falco didn't exactly think that Avatar
the way of water was going to fail she
thought that it had already failed as
one of the most ambitious sci-fi films
of all time James C R's 2022 sequel
needed a whole lot of post- production
to properly transport viewers to Pandora
editing and effects took years to
complete so actors had to be captured on
camera quite a while before the movie
was released it took long enough that
Falco assumed the way of water in which
Chief plays General Francis Ardmore had
already come out flopped at the box
office and been forgotten during a 2023
appearance on The View Falco explained
that she filmed her scenes for Avatar 2
4 years earlier and moved on to other
projects since she hadn't heard anything
about it for a while she assumed that it
had simply come and Gone without much
fanfare somebody mentioned Avatar and I
thought oh I guess it came out and
didn't do very well cuz I didn't hear
anything so I bet it happens you know it
was only when excitement ramped up for
the way of water that Falco realized it
hadn't hit theaters yet but she was
happy to learn that it hadn't been a
failure after all nobody could have
predicted back in 1939 that Gone With
the Wind was going to be discussed and
held to Loft as an all-time classic film
near nearly a century later of course
the people making it must have at least
known they were making a good movie
right well certainly some of the cast
and crew did but that list doesn't
include Vivian Lee who played Scarlet
O'Hara in the historical romance epic in
letters discovered by The Hollywood
Reporter between Lee and her second
husband Lawrence Olivier neither actor
had high hopes for gone with the win and
Olivier even worried about the damage it
was going to do to Lee's still Rising
career Olivier wrote to Lee you have got
to justify yourself in the next two or
three three films or even 2 or 3 years
by proving that the presumable failure
of Gone With the Wind was not your fault
and you can only do that by being really
good in the following parts before a
single review was released in the papers
the couple were already planning Lee's
career comeback after how badly Gone
With the Wind was apparently going to
humiliate her instead she ended up
winning her first of two Oscars for her
work in the film which is the highest
grossing movie of all time by a fairly
wide margin if you adjust for
inflation